well who might you be pretty little  thing I'm Josie I just moved in the  other night thinking all right out here  everything's just fine things  hey Josie you wanted you someone me  Marcus what you don't like him  well no I can just fine  there's some rumors about you no one  knows about me before I came here I'm  sure you were lonely Hank Johnson  company but a young girl that is not the  answer you ain't gotta worry about that  you a bad guy what you think you know  about me  I watched you I know  torments you  just kidding you will suffer the head I  promise  Wow you learnt a little girlfriend you  like that what kind of guard are you  [Music]  you